abone ol
Ama
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
bu şarkıyla çıkmak istedim Çünkü bu
şarkı bana hayallerimin Hayal olmaktan
çıkmasının kendi yarattığım duvarları
yıkmakla ilgili olduğunu hissettirir çok
severim Mutlu olduğumda dinlerim
açıkçası o yıktığım Hayallerde o
duvarların altında kaldığında dinlerim
oradan çıkmak için
da tıpkı şu anda mutlu olduğum gibi çok
mutluyum çok mutlu olurken de hep
dinlerim bugün burada sizlerin
karşısında isen sebebim Hayallerim Hayal
içinde kurduğum Hayaller Canım babam Çok
mutlu olduğunda söyle derdi Göltaş atıp
altında durasım mı
ya ben bu ne zaman ondan duysam bunu hep
yapmak istemiştim açıkçası çok tereddüt
ettim ama şurada bir kere yapayım Hiç
olmazsa hayatında bir kere şunu denemiş
olayım dedim üstüme gelmedi ama olsun
bu
o kadar mutlu oluyorum ki üstüme taş
yağsa da vız gelir hali
ve bu heyecanlı ve mutlu olma hali
Aslında benim genel durum Hemen her şeyi
daha eğlenceli hale getirmek benim
güçlüklerle başa çıkmayı oğlum
bu hikaye Denizli'nin Güney ilçesinde
başlıyor Denizi'nin kuzeyindeki bu
küçücük ilçede kurduğum hayallerle
Ben ilkokuldayken küçük abim
saimb liseli devrimci bir genç
Sen bana dünyanın en güzel hediyesi
veriyor kitap okuma alışkanlığı
bu hayal içinde Hayal kurmak İşte o
zamandan başlıyor abimin Deniz lisesinde
ne ve her geldiğinde
çantasından çıkacak yeni kitapları
heyecanla beklediğim hatırlıyorum
açıkçası günlerce deyim yerindeyse Nefes
almadan uyumadan kitap okuduğumu
annemden yeter gari gözüm bozulacak
hazarların hatırlıyorum ablamdan İş
yapmamak için kitap okuyor
dediklerine her okuduğum kitapta
zenginleşen Hayal dünyamı
kitapların içinde buldum kendimi o
kahramanla Kahraman o karakterle o
karakter olduğumu tüm bunların da çocuk
olarak yapacak hiçbir şeyin olmadığı
güneyde çok kıymetli olmasını mı
çocukluğumda bir çocuk Parkı'nın bile
olmadığı güneyde Ben okuduğum
kitaplardan bildiğim şatolar bu
üzüm cümleleriyle yapmayı hayal edip bu
po hayali hayatta getirmekle başladım bu
dünyaya
ve hayallerimin içinde kendimi Oh an
içinde bulurum Oradan da başka hayallere
geçerim mesela ilk hayalim ben bu ilçede
okumayacağım buradaki çevre ve aile
sistemi içinde kalmayacağım the
İyi o zaman bunu demişimdir ama bugün
burada daha havalı bir teşhis koyarsam
aile ve çevre baskısının şekillendirdiği
çerçevelere sığmamış sebebi budur
Burk küçük bir kız çocuğu olarak o gün
Kurduğum hayallerin içinden bambaşka
yerlere Gitsem de Paya kurmaktan hiç
vazgeçmedim
şu
bu hayal kurma hali o küçük Kızken
öykünün düğüm amcam Yasin Tokat'ın Güney
imizi Türkiye'nin en önemli
şaraplık bağ Merkezi yapma hayallerine
ortak olmamla başladı O bu hayali hayata
geçirirken Ben bir yerinden bu hayali
ortak oldum küçük bir Ege
kasabasından Türkiye'nin Hatta dünyanın
en önemli şaraplık bal Merkezi
yarattığımız hayalleri gerçeğe taşıma
halidir hep sabırla sevgiyle Ve
özveriyle şuna inanırım
hayallerinize ortak edilirseniz Hayal
Hayal olmaktan çıkar hayata geçer bu
işte ben önce amcamın sonra ailemin
hayallerine ortak oldum şimdi genlerin
Yasin ve Fevzi Benim hayallerim ortak
oluyor Umarım ve dilerim ki kızım Susam
urumda onların hayallerini ileriye
Taşıyan olur su samuru tabi Aslında adı
suyu geçenlerde bir arkadaşım
O da anlattı ona da birisi ya bu Selda
Tokat ne kadar eğlenceli bir kadın kızın
adını da su samuru koymuş dedi demiş
Hakkatten bu başka bir hal eğlence ile
iş yapma hali diyorum buna hayatı
eğlence ile yaşarken bunu hayatıma Daha
iyi olanları aktarabilmek diyorum su
samuru isminin gerçek sandı hikayesi
duyduğumuzda Biz Tabii ki Çok güldük Ama
buna inanılması bu eğlenceli bir parçası
olması hiç tanımadığım birinin hem de
beni ayrıca mutlu etti
ay al ortaklarına geri dönersem
hayalin Hayal olmaktan çıkıp Hayat
olması için en önemlisi Hayal Ortakları
demiştim Bu benim için evde namıdiğer
sus hamur oluyor anne olarak ona
duygularımı anlatmak için yaşamımı
anlatmak onu hayallerime dair etmekte
oluyor GTA V Z kuşağı kızımın bana
verdiği geri bildirimleri önemsemekle
işte ise 2000l ve her birinin fikrini
emeğini benim için kıymetini onlara
hissettirmek LB onları özeniyorum ve
hemen her hayalimi ortak etmeye gayret
ediyorum
ailemle çok kıymetli dostlarımla doğrusu
her birinin bir parça katkısıyla
Evet bu da altını çizmeliyim ki
samimiyetlere özenme ile oluyor samimice
anlatma Ayla Detaylara Özen meyle Bir de
sabırla
bu heyecanlı olma halinde sabır biraz
avcılık gelmiş olabilir Size
Eğer heyecanla bir hayal kur duysam bu
hayatta geçsin diye Sabretmeyi öğrendim
den bahsediyorum sabırsızlık Bana sabrı
öğretti Aslında Herşey birbiriyle
ilintili Hayal kurmak kurduğum Hayal
içinde yaşamak
paylaşmaya özenmek samimi olmak bundan
heyecan duymak sabırsızca sabretmek
Bu bir markamızın hayata geçmesi sanırım
geçmesi için sanırım 10 sene
beklemişliğim var ya hakikaten taş olsa
çatlar öyle bir sabır ama çok inandığım
Bir Hayal ise
sonuçlanmasını beklemek asla yılmamak
ve O hayal oyunun içinde Hep bir sonraki
aşamasını yaşamak Bak mesela ben o
markanın hayal kurmaktan hiç vazgeçmedim
heyecanlı ilk anlattığımda Yok olmaz
diyen herkese rağmen bir gün sık
kafelerin Şahane kadın masalarında
ellerinde o şarabımızı içen herkese hep
hayal ettim sadece bu hayalim de olduğu
gibi Bazen hayal ortaklarıyla
buluşturmak için o hayalini güzelce
paketleyip bir o koymam gerekti bu
bu hayal Ortağım bu şarabımız da yeğenim
Fevzi oldu O da inandı ve inandığında bu
harika şarabı Tam da hayal ettiğim gibi
yaptı bu sonra iki BİM oldu Onlar bu
harika şarabı Tamda hayalet tipi
insanlarla buluşturdu Tüm bu inanmıştık
ortak heyecan başarıyı getirdi Burada en
önemlisi yılmam aktı doğru zaman
olmuyorsa doğru zaman beklemek baz
geçmemek bu ara ara ara özellikle
koyduğum o rafa uzanıp elime almak bir
kez daha denemek olmuyorsa tekrar aynı
özelliği o rafa koymak
zamanı geldiğinde
artık kafamda netleşen fotoğrafı hayata
geçirmek her zaman hayallerimi Hayal
Ortakları mı Hayata geçirebilirdim bu
örnekte olduğu gibi
bitümün hikayede En renkli zamanlar İşte
o hayata geçirme zamanları hoplaya
zıplaya oradan oraya koştururken insan
hiç Yorulmaz bu neşeniz arkası sirayet
eder vs böyle bir şeydir çok güçlü bir
duygudur
bu duruma Siz Tutku ben ve Coşku diyeyim
Nasılsın sorusuna
herkesi kıskandıracak kadar iyiyim diyen
bir babanın kızıyım
Ya ben herkesi kıskandıracak bir iş
yapıyorum
şanslıyım böyle bir ailede doğdum
ailem ya tornavida Ne bileyim İngiliz
anahtarı falan üret Seydi elimde 13-14
sonun anahtarıyla oradan oraya koşarken
hiç sofistike olmazdım biliyorum havlu
gibi ben şimdi Elimde bir kadehle hatta
bazen bir şeyle Türkiye'yi ve Dünyayı
Geziyorum
yeğenlerime kızıma
devredeceğim onları ortak ettiğim uzun
soluklu bir hayalin peşinden koşuyorum
bu hayal çoraplarınızı bir gün tüm dünya
tanıyacak
epey yol kat ettik Aslında inanıyorum ki
burada sabırla sevgiyle
heyecanımızı hiç Yitirmeden ve kendimize
kattığımız yeni Hayal ortaklarımızla
belki sizlerle bunu gerçekleştireceğiz
Elimde bir şişeyle Türkiye'yi ve Dünyayı
Geziyorum dedim
Biz bunu mecazi anlamda söylemiyorum
hemen her farklı Ülke İş seyahatinde
elime birşey şarabımızı alıyorum ve o
şarapla O ülkeye geziyorum
gerçekten de onu kendime seyahat
arkadaşı ilan ediyorum sanki o bir şişe
değil de canlı kanlı bir insan gibi
sosyal medyada sağolsunlar çokça Hayal
ortağım var Onlara müteşekkirim
o orada seyahati mi Anam yazıyorum tüm
İçten duygularla neşenle şuraya gittik
şurada yız ya çok yorulduk bir kahve
içiyoruz
gibii diye diye geziyorum Geçen yine
böyle bir seyahatten döndüm Amcam aradı
böyle deli gibi dedi
düşündüm daha onunla konuşurken Evet ya
ben çok eğlendim ama beni okuyanlarda
amcamla herşeyi düşünmüş olabilirler
dedim yetti artık demiş olabilirler
dedim kendime sonra da şunu açıkladım o
sosyal medya hayali ağaçlarıma O biraz
abartmış olabilirim vallahi kusura
bakmayın Bu yoğun koşuşturma ile başa
çıkmak için
böyle şeyler yapıyorum Ayrıca çok
eğlendim be yazdım bu samimi olma hali
önemsiyorum çünkü hatta çok önemsiyorum
Hatta benim bütün numaram bu samimi olma
halinde diyebilirim samimice hayallerimi
hayal kırıklıklarını paylaşmanın
hayallerin hayata geçmesinde önemli
olduğuna inanıyorum
samimiyet paylaşılabilen hissedilebilen
anlaşılabilen bir duygu Ben de bu
duyguya özeniyorum sabır ve özenle
dönecek olursam o hayali bu
özel ve kaldırdığım o raftan tekrar
elime aldığımda her ama her detayıyla
uğraşarak hayata geçiriyorum çevremdeki
herkesi delirten detaylarla günlerce
uğraşsam da bazen bir markanın
başlığındaki bir renkli tayı gibii günün
sonunda Elime aldığım sonuçtan sadece
ben değil emek veren herkes tüm ekip
aile o belirttiğim her tedarikçi hep
birlikte mutlu oluyorsak Bu duygu
Samet'le paylaşmaktan geçiyor ben bu
anlarda da çok mutlu oluyorum gedaş atıp
altında durmak istiyorum O zamanlar E
tabi her şey bu kadar güllük gülistanlık
değil ama herşeyden önce şarap yapmanın
şarap satmanın
almanın ve içmenin yasaklanmasını
isteyen bir zihniyetle üretiyoruz uzunca
süredir gün geçmiyor ki yeni bir yasak
olmasın Biz bu zorluklarla yılmadan
vazgeçmeden sabırla çalışarak başa
çıkabiliyoruz heyecanınızı hep canlı
tutarak sizler gibi dostlarım desteğiyle
E ben Defol yanma değilim
ortalıkta poljana gibi dolaşmıyorum öfke
lerim
kıskançlıklar Imm ve hayal kırıklıklarım
var elbette a Elbette hayallerimde o
duvarları yıkarken altında kalmışlığın
Davaro o yılmadan bıkmadan sabırla o
tuğlaları teker teker kaldırmak
gerekiyor Bunu biliyorum her şeyden önce
olumsuz her şeye bakışım Aslında bu bir
dakika her şeyin bir çaresi vardır bakış
açısı hele dur şuradan başlayayım
dediğimde şu düğümü çözmekle başlayayım
dediğimde bütün düğümler çözülüyor
olaya küsmeden o soruna kahrolmadan
fotoğrafın dışına çıkıp o ilk düğümü
bulmakta başlıyor çözüm bir de şu var
ya dalga geçmeye başlarsam hele sorunla
çok daha kolay çözülüyor eğer o şeyle
altında kaldığım duvar Hayal
kırıklıkları yasaklar
topyekûn defanslar diyeyim dalga geçmeye
başlayabiliyor Sam önemli bir yol kat
etmiş oluyorum inanıyorum ki eğlence
ve eylence hali sorunları küçültür
küçülen sorunda daha çabuk çözülür
neşeli olma hali herşeye iyi gelir
Gülümsemek bütün kapıları açar hem
Gülümsemek devrimci de bir eylemdir başa
çıkmayı the and Üzel su samuru 45
yaşlarında öğretti bana bir gün arabada
gidiyoruz o arkada gerçekten çok
düşündüm ama anımsamıyorum sebebini Bir
Sebeple ona bu söylendim söylendim de
söylendim bayağı kızdım ben önde
duyguları Yüzümde Sevda araba kullanıyor
beş karış da arkada su aynı biliyor
musun Ben Böyle zamanlarda
Ben kendime hep minik su
birazdan okuduğum bu kitaptaki kötü
sayfalar gidecek ve güzel sayfalar
gelecek diyorum dedi
O çok acayip bir Metafor ben çok severim
ama minik suda bir şekilde öğrenmiş
pişse sudan
çok minik sudan da bunu öğrendim her
türlü olumsuzluğa Selda Az bekle demeyi
dönüp dönüp aynı şeyleri anlatıyorum
önce Hayaller
sonra vazgeçmemek
Ya sabır
özel samimiyet
Yok canım babacığım
Bu bir konuda tekrar a düşenlere eu
uzunca anlatanlara şeylerdi bir şeye
faydası varsa getirsin bari
o uzatma artık demenin başka bir yolu
Bence İşte ben de o zaman Dayım bir şeye
faydası varsa getirsin
Garibin kilo ile başladım fil pilotla
bitirmek istiyorum her birinize
hayallerinizde kendi yarattığınız
duvarları samimice
özenle sabırla yapmanız dileğiyle
[Alkış]